So the intensity of a
cluster headache in its maximum
form is like a knife stab in the
eye Markus saffes from
clusterhexion the CAN effect people
the life
plus theedex to the
mixation
installed here behind this cheekbone
it was like a newborn
it was a devastating pain that
one in  The chemistry is forcing and
I actually don't know of any
comparable pain Markus experience
Cluster Hatice seven
So the psychological effects of these
phases were quite
intense because I even
struggled with suicidal thoughts at times because
I couldn't imagine
living a long life with this pain  to have to for blanket
now he managedition with medication
and sex his and become leading to
frequent hospitalizations
in the care
at the
Münster University Hospital, I heard
about a
non-drug therapy for the first time  I
hope that this
could help me too. The stimulator is
installed here behind this cheekbone.
The remote control is needed
to operate the stimulator, so to speak,
but also and above all to bring the energy
into the device
The stimulator really
fulfilled this function very well, it was
like a new birth.
I had the hope that I would now be able to grow old
without pain and that
gave me a new courage to live. I was
able to leave these depressive dark phases behind me. It was simply like a
new life,
Martin
Trading a thousand thoughts and
panic, some of which threatened
to overwhelm me on some days, especially when I was feeling
really bad, it was difficult
to keep these thoughts in the dream
and not to go back to an old pattern. The
market is easy,
I knew that the stimulator was all  After
a few months it has to be replaced after a
year at the latest because the battery
just
stopped working. How can I manage it in the
future without this company?
Company Markus need it finding solution
and lucky background
I'm an electrical engineer so I have a
certain understanding of the
technology there  With
friends I found out that I was
able to repair the device again
Markus
lifeline and
ready for use I held the device
to my cheek and was
overjoyed that it worked,
but at that moment I also
realized
that future repairs would not be possible  The
battery may affect my
skills or my abilities, overtax my
tools,
make
television,
white
what's more in somecasties
osters Live expensive
with light on the horizon what makes me
hopeful for the future is
that there is an actual successor
for the device a newcompany code
really for  the quiet the painful way
simplant and plants
over placement
starts and can't
realize it then
I don't know what the future will be like